I'm standing in front of a fryer three
axis CNC milling machine this is a large
machine I'm standing ten feet away just
to soak it all in with this camera we'll
be examining different parts of the
machine right now this is the spindle
where the cutting tools are mounted this
is the part of the machine which rotates
it's all attached to the z-axis and it
can move vertically up and down on the
side of this spindle is a gray handle
which releases something called the
quill this black handle moves the
spindle up and down when you want to use
the milling machine as a very accurate
drill press otherwise you rarely use the
quill feature the table of the machine
is large it moves about 30 inches left
and right and in and out approximately
20 inches it has three slots mounted on
it a beautiful carousel built by Walter
will hold our tools and here are the
three T slots in the table they're
actually inverted T's and things called
tea nuts can be slid into these slots to
hold various things down it is possible
to hold parts directly to the tabletop
as well as a vise when you want to clamp
a part directly to the tabletop you
would use something called a table clamp
it's attached to a tea nut it slides
into the slot and it can be used to
clamp down an object you would need at
least two of these keep in mind it is
possible for the milling machine to cut
into its own table there is no safety
feature built into the machine to
prevent that the vise is also a very
commonly used device for holding objects
in the milling machine and we will be
making use of that all the time in the
back of the machine is an oil system
which pumps oil to lubricate the ways
and bearings of the machine there is
also compressed air used to do tool
changing and of course electricity is
the main power source to turn on the
machine you turn the gray knob in the
back and the red knob on the side inside
the yellow square when the machine
time's up the Anna lamb 3000
touch-sensitive liquid screen powers up
it's filled with many user buttons which
we will discuss later one of the first
things you'll have to do is power on the
servo motors you first have to make sure
the emergency stop is not activated by
twisting it to the right it will pop out
and then you push the servo reset button
to reset the servos at this juncture you
will have to hit the home button the f4
key and the homing process will take
place sped up you will see the z-axis
goes all the way to the top the y-axis
comes all the way at you and the x-axis
goes all the way to the left at that
point the machine will read X Y Z 0
before describing how to actually move
the CNC axes let's keep in mind that the
machine is designed so that the table
makes X&Y movements while the z-axis
makes the up-and-down movements thinking
of the table moving around is extremely
confusing we will therefore pretend that
the table is stationary and the spindle
makes all the movements with this
assumption the familiar Cartesian
coordinate system will remain in effect
and these XY axes can be thought of as
being directly on top of the CNC table
in this way your programming will be
made much much easier because the
spindle appears to be moving to the
right
x- or y+ y-
to go over the motion of the machine
again and to show you the difference
between line moves and rapid moves
we have zeroed the machine on that
corner and it is now going to make a
six-inch rapid move to the right
positive six inches why because it
looked like the spindle went to the
right thinking of table movement will
drive you crazy that's why positive to
point five and this is a rapid move back
to zero zero these moves are made by
entering them onto the keypad by
selecting rapid and then entering the
coordinate you want to go to this is now
a line move from x equals zero to x
equals six remember the spindle is
moving to the right positive six it's
you have to enter a feed rate here it is
20 inches a minute
rapid moves are used to rapidly go with
a tool to start cutting and then you
switch to line moves to actually make a
milling cut I'm now going to enter a
line move in three directions at the
same time you push the line button and
up comes the line menu I'm going to
enter x equals six y equals two point
five Z equals negative ten with a feed
rate of 20 zyne egative ten will bring
the z-axis up because it's right now
around negative 16 when executed you
need to push the execute button the tip
of this drill sped up will will sweep
out a space diagonal it is complex
three-dimensional movement like this
which makes milling 3d complex
geometries possible
okay I just want to show once again
using the pulse generator it's really
simple you click that to the x-axis if
you want to move it with this in 100
every time I move this it moves a tenth
of an inch every time it makes a little
click and you can make very coarse
movements with this if you reduce it to
10 it moves a thousandth of an inch
every time it's moving very slowly now
and believe it or not you can move it in
one ten thousandth of an inch increments
the same thing is true for y
and if I select the Z this is one of the
most useful ways of removing the
accidents this area here there are jog
buttons now jogging in the middle there
is a button that has a hand on it and
that's for like hand movement jogging
I'm going to hit the jog button and
every time I hit the jog button next to
the word jog it says one I hit it again
it says rapid I hit it again it says
speed I hit it again
it says a hundred and ten now I'm in
inches now and a movement of one would
be one ten thousandth of an inch a
movement of ten would be ten thousandth
of an inch and a rapid we'll just go
rapidly so for example in rapid if I hit
X positive it will go positive X
negative it will go negative let me
discuss how to remove the tool from the
machine
the first thing we're going to notice
it's the quill on the side the first
thing we're going to want to do is to
unmake sure this handle is up and
unlocked and make sure the quill is all
the way up the tool will not come out
unless the spindle is all the way up now
we're going to just lock this down today
we're going to focus our attention along
are these in/out buttons that are
located right above the spindle on the
left side notice there's a green button
on the outside and
out red button top and bottom - should
we move the tool you push and hold in
the green button while hitting the out
button and you'll hear the air pressure
when you do that now let's focus in on
the spindle when I hold in the green
button and the output and at the same
time the tool is going to come out and
notice that the spindle is dropping when
the tool comes out I'm free now to
change tools now notice there are
notches here and in here there are also
a corresponding set of notches now to
put the tool back in you have to rotate
this around until fits into those
notches then you hold the green button
in until the tool is back in there this
particular method of tool changing
called the power drawbar system is a
manual tool changing method however it
is fairly quick and part of the machine
that has the power this is what this is
where it is a power lock system that is
the part of the machine which does the
tool change
now you're probably all familiar with
device but this particular vice it has
this handle that opens and closes the
Vice it is held into the table with
these tea nuts again we are using tea
nuts that have threads coming out of
them and the screws are tightened with
the same handle as you would tighten the
vise with ships often get inside a vise
so if you're using a vise it's very
important if you want accuracy to make
sure the inside of the vise is extremely
clean we do have an air gun mounted on
to the side of this machine here is the
air gun blasts compressed air it's
sometimes something you don't always
want to use a compressed air gun but it
can be useful do never play around with
these in the shop clip typically when
you use a vise you would put a piece of
metal in device like this however you
never know if the metal is angled this
way or potentially it could be angled
this way and if you want it flat use
these ground precision ground pieces of
metal call parallels now we have sets of
parallels they come in many different
sizes you have to sort of select one
that's appropriate to your machining
task and then when you put your piece of
metal in the vise
it holds evenly down on the parallels
and you're guaranteed that the top of
your material is relatively flat it's
also important that you tap down
slightly piece of material when you
tightening it in a vise because
sometimes when you tighten it it can
lift up and it's essential to tap it if
you want to protect the material from
the little bang marks that might occur
with the ball on this handle you would
put something over a piece of wood or
something to tap it down
I have to describe to you exactly the
method by which we're going to make
these name plates we've created a jig to
be used in production of these name
plates and this is the way the jig works
it's quite simple
this is the bottom part of the jig and
it's going to go into the vise now I
just want to want you to take note of
how this one corner differs from the
other corners and I'm going to discuss
that in a second but basically this part
of the jig is going to go into the vise
and it's going to stay there for the
entire class the next thing that's going
to happen and I think I mentioned this
to you already is this is the blank
everyone in your class is going to be
given one of these pieces of aluminum it
is approximately six inches long and two
and a half inches wide and it's about a
half an inch thick what you're going to
do is you're going to tap two holes 1/4
by twenty eight threads exactly four
inches apart directly centered on the
bottom of this plate that's the first
thing you're going to do and then what's
going to happen is this you're going to
screw your name plate on to the top of
this jig and tighten these screws then
this particular plate with your name
plate on it will be put on top of the
secondary plate and it will be clamped
on or screwed down with these screws now
these happen to be called Allen cap
screws they take a special sort of
hexagonal wrench to tighten them and
you've probably seen them before and
these will be tightened like this
once your nameplate is down on the jig
these screws tighten below the surface
of at the bottom of the jig they'll come
down like this and we will be free to
machine all the surfaces of this plate
while making your nameplate so we'll be
able to for example change the shape of
this rectangular block into whatever
whatever we want really and the only
thing you kind of have to appreciate is
that to cut in to cut all the way around
your piece and complete the profiling
we're going to have to cut a little bit
into this jig that's okay because these
screws go below the surface and they
were made to do that and we won't go too
far below but while we profiling out
your nameplate we will actually cut into
this into the Plexiglas a little bit now
the reason why we've made the jig like
this is as follows after you make your
nameplate one of your fellow classmates
will want to make his or hers now we
will determine from this corner of the
jig we will set our zero zero of our CNC
machine and everything will be
referenced from the same corner and
therefore when we take out your
nameplate
and replace it with someone else's we
will not have changed our X Y zero and
we won't have to go through the somewhat
time-consuming task of read establishing
the corner of the piece every single
time we change plates so that's why
that's the philosophy of this jig
here are the Allen screws I mentioned
that are on the jig and this is what's
going to hold the nameplate down to that
upper Plexiglas plate on the jig this is
an Allen cap screw you can tell because
it has the hex it uses an Allen wrench
the hex is in here and it happens to be
what's called a 1/4 - 28 screw now what
that means is the screw is 1/4 of an
inch in diameter and it is it has 28
threads per inch so if you could count
these there'd be 28 of these for him we
must tap 1/4 28 hole and in order to do
that we need to determine the drill
needed to make such a hole we consult
the drill chart and see that the quarter
28 hole requires a number 3 drill this
chart also gives you the actual diameter
of these drills drills are listed as
numbered drills fractional size drills
and letter drills all the information
you need is contained in the chart but
the important thing to know is we need a
number 3 drill 0.21 3 inches
hard to see on the camera but here along
the shank of the drill there is an
actual number 3 that is engraved into it
and I will tell you a lot of ice
drilling them so to check it I'm going
to use a caliper now this is a pretty
good one this is an electronic caliper
it's made by a company called Brown &
Sharpe they're in the business of making
precision measurement equipment but let
me just say when you when you pull it
open you see the jaws underneath open up
this one's a digital caliper so it gives
you a digital readout and we can use it
to measure the diameter of this drill so
I'm going to grab the shank and it's
measuring about point two one here you
can also measure the tip if you want and
it's measures about point two one two
now drill bits 10
have the caliper out let me just go over
it a little bit it can measure the
outside diameter down here below with
these jaws and if you look at the top
part that can be used to measure the
inside diameter on the other side of the
caliper where as I pull open the jaw
this rod comes out the bottom and that
can be used to measure the depth of a
hole so this this little device here and
this might be how you would use these
outer jaws to take an inside diameter
measurement okay now I have to tell you
it's not a trivial measurement to make
it's very easy to hold the caliper
cooking this way or that way
it's very easy to measure the diameter
here instead of right in the diameter so
it's always a very tricky measurement
when you measure inside diameter so I'm
just kind of point that out to you when
you're making it inside diameter
measurements you have to be extremely
careful the outside ones are a little
bit more straightforward it's easier to
get the outside one right and of course
the depth of a hole could be measured by
coming in bringing this down on a flat
surface you could make your bet
to prevent oil from being constantly
pumped into the machine we should turn
off the servo motors by pushing big red
to write a program you must hit the
program button and then hit the create
button and then the ASCII key an up
comes a little ASCII touch-sensitive
keyboard and you can type in a name of a
program I am typing in the name drill
after typing it in you hit ASCII again
and when you hit enter you will notice
that on the screen will appear your new
program drill dot M you must select it
with the f6 key and then hit f4 for edit
and you can start writing your program
notice the very that at the very top the
program appears in a very small font
size drill dot M all these programs have
dot M's and below the screen is the last
line of all programs the end of program
line that's sort of a generic line that
is popped on to the end of all programs
the first thing we're going to do is hit
the number 7 key and select our units
I'm picking inches the plus sign will
toggle between millimeters and inches
the next thing we're going to do is pick
absolute coordinates again the plus sign
will allow you to pick incremental but
we will select absolute the first thing
we're going to do of any significance is
a tool change command when you hit the
number 5 key up comes the tool change
command we are going to ask for tool
number 1 and the M code is M 6 for tool
change that will be our spot drill after
making that tool change I will want to
start the spindle spinning clockwise the
M code for that is M 3 and after that I
will select the RPM with the period
button and select 1000 which is a good
rpm for drilling so slowly but surely
our program is starting to form after
selecting the tool I'm going to rapidly
move to the start point of where I
want to drill so my first hole is at x-
2 because the center is 0 0 y 0 and I'm
coming down to the coordinate zero point
1 in the Z direction we're now in a
position to start drilling so I hit the
drill menu and I'm going to select the
kind of hole I want to drill first that
is the way this philosophy of this
machine works I select basic drilling
because this is a simple spot drill and
there's a little picture that diagrams
how the drilling process will go we're
going a depth of negative o5 our start
height will be zero point one our return
height will also be zero point one and
we'll feed slowly to peak to be
conservative at two inches a minute when
we enter this line all the information
will appear the next thing we want to do
is re-enter the drill menu and we will
select pattern now we only have to drill
two holes and I could simply put in the
coordinate information of those two
holes but to show capability of the
machine will bring up the drill pattern
menu and here we are in a position if we
wanted to to drill hundreds of holes but
we only need two our first one is at
negative two zero we have two holes in
the X direction and one in the Y and the
increment in the X Direction is 4 inches
so it's kind of a lot of work for two
holes but you get the idea after
entering this command we are in a
position to check to see if we are
programming correctly now all the
information we really need is there it's
going to do the basic drilling described
on line seven and it's going to apply it
to the pattern of holes described on
line eight in our program and again
that's the philosophy of the machine to
check our program will hit the draw
button F
- once the draw button is hit there are
a couple of options under the draw menu
and one is to select the view and we
will select the XY plane which is a top
view and the display will hit fit and up
on the screen you can see the two holes
that will be drilled one at negative two
and the other one at positive two
the next thing we must do at the end of
all drilling operations you must enter
what's called the drilling off command
it tells a machine to stop drilling
so that's necessary as well now the
second hole is almost exactly like the
first hole so by copying and pasting
lines and then editing them it'll make
life easier now copying and pasting is a
little weird on this machine so you must
get into the menus you've just seen hit
the more button and bring up the mark
line when you enter the mark line it
will allow you to highlight the lines
that you wish to copy this is somewhat
of an archaic programming method but
nonetheless it does work we are going to
highlight lines three all the way down
to line nine the drill off command we're
going to copy and paste it and then
we're going to edit it for our second
drilling operation you hit more again
and it will bring up the copy command so
we'll select copy next and when you hit
enter notice it says block saved now all
we have to do is move the cursor down
one line and then we will select the
paste command and all those lines will
be pasted above line number ten so we
hit more one more time go down to paste
hit enter and we have copied the blocks
of programming to the next line so as
you can see you have tool number one to
the drill off command and then tool
number one once again to the drill off
command we're going to enter line ten so
we can edit it and we're going to change
tool number one to tool number two now
this will be our number three drill
which will we be used to tap to drill
the hole for the quarter twenty-eight
now everything else is reasonably good
but to show the capabilities of the
machine we're going to rather than do a
basic drilling operation we're going to
use a pecking drilling operation so I'm
going to go to 14 and hit the Clear
button and that erases that line
and now I'm going to go back to the
drill program or the drill menu and this
time instead of selecting basic drill we
will select what's called pecking now
pecking is a cycle that's normally used
for deep hole drilling and the idea is
like a bird pecking at its feed the
drill bit will go down to the depth you
program it to but it will do it in
little pecking increments each time
bringing the drill out and clearing the
chips from the hole and I'm entering the
pertinent information we're going down
negative 0.375 the start and return
height are the same and I'm going to
pick 0.1 pecks so it's going to Peck 3.1
pecks and then the final Peck will be
0.075 so we'll make for pecks for each
hole which is a bit ludicrous for a
piece of aluminum but again just to show
you the capabilities of the machine and
again we'll select a feed rate of two
and basically our entire program is done
before running our program it is
necessary to obtain the tool offsets now
when the machine is first hold the tool
that's put into the machine is a
fictitious tool called tool number zero
this is where the tool changes are made
since we are using tool number one we
now have to switch this to tool number
one having switched it by hitting the
number-5 button and pushing tool number
one we have to actually execute this
command to make it happen so we hit the
green execute button and the machine
won't move because there was no movement
involved but the tool has been changed
to tool number one the next step is to
slowly move tool number one down until
it just touches the surface of the piece
of material I'm using a small piece of
paper that I am wiggling back and forth
as I slowly lower the tool down when the
paper stops wiggling I know that I have
achieved my my surface touch I now look
at the Machine coordinates now this
little box here are the machine
ordinates this is what has to be entered
into the tool table you hit the f9 key
to bring up the tool table and in the
number one line tool number one we must
enter the diameter and its length offset
the big coordinate information in the
upper left left hand screen these
numbers there are the part coordinates
but it is the Machine coordinates which
are crucially important for doing tool
offsets I enter the tool length offset
in this particular example the two
numbers agree with each other but they
typically do not now we must play the
same game with tool number two so I
enter tool number two command and I'll
have to hit execute again after entering
this information to make tool number two
come out now we must lower the number
three drill on to the surface of the
material wiggling the paper as we go you
can either use the pulse generator to
lower the z-axis or the jog buttons but
it must be done slowly and carefully
once this height is obtained you must
enter it also into the tool table now
notice this Zee machine is sixteen point
o2 to negative sixteen point O to two
and the number in the tool table is
negative sixteen point O two one nine
this must be because somebody recently
got the offset and it's just off by a
thousandth so we will make it perfect
and we will have completed entering the
tool length offset into the machine
before we can run our drill program we
must turn back on the servo motors so to
do this you twist the big red knob to
the right it pops out you will get some
messages that will come up on the screen
and you'll have to clear them and then
you hit the reset servo button and after
that the servos will come on and the oil
will start pumping again and we'll be
ready to move the axes and run our
program before we can run the program we
must zero the x and y-axes
on the center of the nameplate I've
lowered the spot drill down to the
center
hit the X&Y yellow buttons and enter
zero and that will zero the X y-axis at
the center to run a program will hit the
miscellaneous button and that takes us
to the menu that we run the program from
when you see that Auto button light up
then you know you're able to run a
program you hit the auto button and what
comes up is press Start to execute or
manual to cancel so we are now ready to
run the program we will hit the green
execute button now the knob next to the
big red emergency stop button allows you
to crank down or crank up the speed of
the pre-programmed feed rates so every
move whether it be rapid or a feed move
can be cranked far below what it was
programmed for or somewhat above it now
that when we turn on the program the
very first thing is a tool change
command - tool number one notice that
tool number two is in the machine so we
have to switch it to tool number one
happening after having done that we hit
the execute button it cranks up the
spindle just like we programmed it to
and it's going to drill the to spot
holes the coolant has been applied with
a squirt bottle however it's cool and
can be made to come out of the machine
with an m8 code the next thing is a tool
change for number two we change up that
tool and hit execute again and the next
drilling process will take place realize
that we're now seeing pecking drill it's
a little bit different you'll see the
drill go up and down several times
before completing the depth of the hole
and after it completes drilling our two
holes the program will come to an end
and that's all there is to it
it's time now to tap the holes and to
make sure the tap goes in straight we're
going to use this spring-loaded tip it's
going to be put into the spindle and
then the spindle is going to be brought
right on top of the hole to help guide
the tap the tap is attached to a tap
handle and we are going to be manually
tapping these holes it is always
necessary to use tapping compound while
tapping holes otherwise you stand a good
chance of breaking the tap I should warn
you now that when a tap gets broken
inside a hole it is very difficult
usually impossible to remove it
frequently you have to start the entire
job over again we move the tip right
over the hole bring the z-axis down a
little bit to create some tension in the
tip and that will keep the tap going
straight for tapping holes the rule is
to go one revolution clockwise followed
by a quarter revolution counterclockwise
that quarter revolution counterclockwise
is done to break off the chips if the
chips continue to pile up inside the
hole that too can lead to a broken tap
once the tap has been started by this
technique you can finish it off by
taking the tip up and just tapping the
hole once again when when you're a
novice at doing this breaking taps is
pretty common so I'm just warning you be
careful when you tap holes quarter
twenty eights fairly large size tap it's
not likely to break but when you're
using smaller taps you have to be even
more careful we'll play the same game on
the right side lowering the tip down and
in a short amount of time that hole is
too tapped